if you want to know
how best to structure and
structure a questionnaire then this video is the
right one for you this video is our
first video on the subject of questionnaire
construction if you like you can
read the content in our book questionnaire
made easy
you can find the link  in the video description
we start with a small overview of
everything in your questionnaire
on the rhine side at the beginning of a questionnaire
comes the introductory text then the
opening question followed by the question
blocks the main part of the questionnaire at the end there are the socio-
demographic questions and the
final question and now we go
we start
with the introductory text what goes
into the introductory text at the beginning of the introductory
text you should
briefly introduce yourself dear participants
dear participants my name is max
mustermann and i study pedagogy
afterwards you can briefly talk about
your st  as part of
my
tailor-made work, i am investigating the influence
of video tutorials on the learning success
of female students and
would like to ask you a few questions about this,
but make sure that you do not go into too much
detail on the topic or the
research question than you
If you don't want to influence your respondents, you can then name the processing time for the
questionnaires. I would appreciate it if you
could take 10 minutes to
fill out the questionnaire.
You can also
give tips on how to process it. Please fill out the questionnaire
completely  you
still have to deal with data protection. of
course you have to check what
is relevant for you here. the data from this
survey will be treated anonymously and the
results cannot be attributed to individual
persons. you have now completed
the introductory text for a
questionnaire and can move on to the next point
ov  The opening question
should be a simple
question that is easy for everyone
to answer and introduces the topic.
It should therefore provide a good introduction to
the topic and pick up the respondents personally. It is difficult to give
a general recommendation for an opening question
, as
it depends very much on the topic  depends one
possibility is to ask an open
question in which
the interviewees enter their first thoughts on the topic what
comes to your mind spontaneously when
you think of online teaching we have now
ticked off the first two points and
can now come to the main part of the
questionnaire  The
survey relevant to the research topic begins with the questionnaires. Of course,
you must first
know which characteristics you need for the
individual questions
or hypotheses and
how you can then query these characteristics. Characteristics
that are interesting for your investigation
will then
have an effect in individual questions or  item
batteries queried an item is a
statement in which you ask the degree of
agreement or rejection r make
sure that your question
blocks are structured thematically questions that belong to
a topic should be asked
one after the other this helps
your respondents to recognize the common thread of the
questionnaire  and makes
it easier for you to answer. there are
characteristics that you can easily ask about,
such as a person's age or weight,
then there are so-called latent
or hidden characteristics, such as
intelligence, physical well-being
or environmental awareness. these
latent characteristics are
usually queried  several questions used you can find more about this
in our video
zoellick scale but caution in 95 percent of cases
it is not about thinking about these
questions yourself usually
a clean literature and scales
research leads to the questions with these
validated scales it is then already
researched  whether the individually
there is a
whole range of measuring instruments on the gesis website of the leibniz institute for social sciences. on
this page you will find tried-and-tested
measuring instruments on various topics
that are open access.
you can find the link in the video description below
In a questionnaire, the socio-
demographic questions
include the central characteristics of the
respondents, e.g. age, gender or
educational qualifications, the
socio-demographic questions do not
necessarily have to do with your hypotheses
, they serve to describe the
sample. This makes it
possible to combine the results of a study with
other studies  to compare which
socio-demographic data you need
depends on a research
topic the classics are gender age level of
education nationality job status
income and marital status at the very
end you can ask your question
for feedback  or ask a
final question there
should be one questionnaire for each
standardized question with clear
answer options open-ended
questions questionnaires should be
used sparingly since this is
quantitative research
compared to the main part of the fund,
however, the final question can be asked open-ended
, for example there is something else
you want to get rid of the topic do you
have further
suggestions for improvement for the product or how do you see the future of
online teachers in the next video
we will continue with the important question
types can use these and
create a questionnaire do you want to create a
questionnaire online look
just go to datatec there
you can easily find detailed
instructions on how to create a question with date up
in the
last video of this series jazz and see you soon